brought to you by the order 1886
discover history's darkest secret hey
everyone you're watching reality check
now this week's episode which is
sponsored by Sony is gonna take us on a
wee trip to 19th century London but not
just any old 19th century London no no
this version of the historical Big Smoke
features lycanthropes steampunk weaponry
and Nikola Tesla the famous Serbian
American inventor is in fact the focus
of our show this week where I'll be
investigating just how close this
fictional Tesla is to his real-life
counterpart
life in London isn't looking so good in
1886 there are problems are plenty a
social class uprising a war with a race
of furry half breeds and most
problematic of all a deadly and highly
contagious case of the muttonchops
fortunately Daniel day-lewis and his
chums who make up the order an ancient
Creed of Knights are here to save the
day but as the famous saying goes many
hands make light work especially of
those hands are brandishing badass
electricity guns
I may have paraphrased slightly and this
is where the father of
alternating-current Aziz often no one
comes in providing the group of monster
fighters with useful tools and devices
and as much as we can tell so far this
mainly comprises things that are capable
of zapping exploding or generally
imbuing death and destruction so how
does this compare to the real-life
Nikola Tesla well in 1886 the 30 year
old Tesla had in fact just resigned from
position in Thomas Edison's lab they
fell out over a misunderstanding about a
bet a rift which would develop into a
full-blown and bitter professional
rivalry known as the war of currents
with Edison championing direct currents
and Tesla alternating currents however
it was New York not London where Tesla
ultimately struck out on his own as a
fully fledged inventor and he was an
incredibly prolific one at that with
over 300 patents to his name throughout
his long career perhaps his biggest
contribution was to develop a motor
which enabled alternating current or AC
to be used directly now this was a big
deal as until this invention came along
AC power had to first be converted to
direct current or DC at a significant
loss of efficiency
nice job Nikola
but did he make weapons like our
fictional Tesla does for the order well
believe it or not Tesla did claim to
have both built and tested a death ray
seriously and his own words the
teleforce weapon would been
concentrating beams of particles through
the free air of such tremendous energy
that they would bring down a fleet of
10,000 enemy airplanes of a distance of
200 miles from defending nation's border
and will cause armies to drop dead in
their tracks that certainly sounds like
a death ray so where is it well there
was never any designs or plans found let
alone a prototype and also letting the
lab assistants that ever work with Tesla
ever spoke of such a device existing so
make of that what you will but that is
as far as the real Tesla went with
creating weapons however fictional Tesla
is clearly taking notes from some of the
research carried out by his factual
counterparts and design of his weaponry
take the art gun this beast charges up
before firing a blast of deadly energy
but this is clearly inspired by Tesla's
work with electricity and particularly
his famous Tesla coil the coil very
simply perched works as a transformer
for alternating current it builds up
voltage using the coils of wire
eventually storing enough charge to let
off a spark into the air for more on
Tesla coils including a great
demonstration check out the resource
page for this episode perhaps the most
believable invention that are fictional
Tesla gives to the Knights in the order
however has nothing at all to do with
zapping people introducing the
communicator this wireless device keeps
the whole team in constant contact
kind of like a yield II walkie talkie
you see Tesla actually started out his
career as a telephone engineer and
worked extensively in the field of
wireless communication he was actually
the first person to ever demonstrate
Wireless comes successfully working
until this day he holds all the original
patents very apps then that he kits out
his order buddies with this piece of kit
and that's it for this week's reality
check as always let me know your
thoughts in the comments box below or
you can contact me on Twitter the next
week we're gonna go back to our part to
all about cheat BOTS so make sure you
join me then
you